enfant il y avait chez moi un livre
précieux un atlas de poche
c'était une vieille édition au design
sobre ma la quatrième de couverture très
très prometteuse plus de dix mille noms
de lieux cités 80 cartons couleurs dont
un grand nombre sur des pliants
je ne compte pas les heures que j'ai
passé là à plat ventre à scruter les
courbes les noms des couleurs à essayer
de trouver ma place je suis né et j'ai
grandi dans les alpes françaises de
parents turcs et j'ai toujours eu ce
sentiment indescriptible d'être un beau
d'asie un bout d'europe des bouts de
truc qui me sens pas en touche depuis
mon enfance je me sens profondément
fragmentée morcelé alors au delà de la
double culture c'est plutôt cette
difficulté à faire sens de tout ce que
je suis ou souhaite être un peu comme si
dans mon jeu j'avais trop de cartes
valeur adultes ça s'est pas du tout
arrangée
parce qu'à chaque rencontre il faut se
présenter en quelques mots
je n'ai jamais réussi à répondre
simplement à ces questions ou du moins
d'une manière qui me paraissent
authentiques complète vrai
on pourrait se dire que quand vous
sentez d'une partie de votre identité de
qui vous êtes une partie de votre
identité de genre ethniques culturelles
sociales cultuelle bref une terre qu'une
partie de qui vous êtes et mémoriser
incomprise jugé voire rejetée bien vous
avez un petit peu tendance à endosser un
costume mal taillé parce qu'il le faut
je vous raconte pas quand une part de
votre identité créé des débats à
l'échelle nationale
très pratique surtout au début de ma vie
professionnelle j'avais un peu tendance
à endosser un costume
voilà pas très adapté parce qu'il le
faut j'ai rencontré au cours de ma vie
professionnelle
d'autres femmes prises dans ses costumes
coincé entre des injonctions souvent
tacite très très souvent contradictoires
les vases iaws et de l'ambition can't et
order je pense souvent isabelle une
expert reconnu dans son domaine qui un
jour m'a avoué qu'avant chaque réunion
elle se répétait une sorte de mantra
très très glauque
isabelle à partir de maintenant tu es un
homme mais je pense aussi à
jean-philippe ce chef d'entreprise qui
me disait sans cesse
non mais sera moi ce truc du leader
autoritaire ça me va pas j'ai pas m a
tapé du poing sur la table parce que ce
qu'on attend d'un bon manager c'est pas
mon style nos vies professionnelles
peuvent être particulièrement violente
à cet égard surtout qu'elle définisse
une grande part qui on est et je sais de
quoi je parle
pour calmer les inquiétudes de la petite
fille moi j'avais trouvé une parade
infaillible
ce que je faisais disait tout de qui
j'étais
c'est super commode de se cacher
derrière un titre un rôle
jusqu'au moment où le père fin 2013 j'ai
vécu l'arrêt de l'activité dans laquelle
je m'étais investi ou pour laquelle
j'avais sacrifié avec passion mes
soirées et week-ends les moments entre
amis
les fêtes de famille alors qu'on
s'entende bien c'était pas grand chose
mais c'était tout pour moi vous avez
peut-être vous aussi vécu cette disons
qu'à sûr de l'identité sociale
je ne sais pas par une période de
chômage et le et toi tu fais quoi
maintenant qui devient très embarrassant
ça peut être aussi les départs des
enfants du domicile familial il faut
réinventer la vie à deux ou tout seul
ou alors le départ à la retraite
expression d'ailleurs très étrange comme
si on se retirait du monde
en bref toutes ces occasions où
l'identité du fer a plus du tout de sens
j'ai compris
pour ma part que cette boulimie de
projets d'activités dans laquelle je me
complaisait est extrêmement facile que
tu es une belle façade mais qu'en
attendant la petite fille elle avait
toujours pas réponses à ses questions à
peu près la même période
camille mon compagnon se préparait pour
partir pour le grand pèlerinage un peu
désoeuvrés j'avoue je les suivis et ça a
été un électrochoc
un de ces rares moments eureka qui
s'offre à vous dans une vie une espèce
de parenthèse de communion avec quelques
2,5 millions de pèlerins venus des
quatre coins du globe le tour du monde
en un seul regard
un hymne à la singularité tous
différents tous reliés là au coeur d'un
atlas vivant entre indonésien yéménite
canadien je me sentis légère et pétri
d'une évidence mais en fait nous
différents sont une richesse et nous
avons tous et toutes une place alors je
conçois
ça paraît très banales mais moi c'est la
première fois que je ressentais cette
vérité dans mes tripes
le pélérinage avait aussi réussi à faire
quelque chose
il avait réussi à rêver la petite fille
vous imaginez bien qu'une enfance à
regarder des cartes surtout quand vous
avez grandi entre quatre vallées à un
moment donné vous avez envie de partir
c'est comme ça qu avec mon compagnon de
camille on a décidé de partir pour de
bon sens itinéraire sans projet sans
date de retour avec pour seul objectif
de s'abandonner à la route à la manière
des derviches errant à la manière des
premiers voyageurs autant dire que pour
l'hyper actif que je suis déjà c'était
un exercice en soit on avait envie de
d'expérimenter ce dépouillement et petit
à petit la mécanique de la route se met
en place
vous mettez à accepter ce qui autrement
serait impensable
surtout quand on est un peu névrosé de
la planification
donc ne pas planifier faire confiance
très souvent on ne savait pas où on
allait dormir où manger le jour même on
s'est allégée matériellement non sans
peine
boutant ou joyau plaisir d'un
minimalisme et d'une frugalité choisi on
avait envie de redonner de la valeur au
temps et de prendre de la distance
de par notre mode de voyage nous avons
partagé le quotidien du plus d'une
cinquantaine de familles à travers toute
l'eurasie vivons sous leur toit à leur
rythme presque dans leurs chaussures ici
avec eux le peuple kalach à la frontière
pakistano afghane
nous avons été littéralement adoptés par
des familles kirghize des familles
russes des familles voirie du pakistan
je ne remercierai jamais assez nos hôtes
avec l'étonnement naïfs d'une enfant
enfin je voyais le monde à travers les
yeux d'autres personnes de personnes
dans le quotidien paraissait
radicalement différent du mien
paraissait je pense souvent irtysh âmes
se perd dans le sud du pendjab
pakistanais avec qui on a passé pas mal
de temps qui a un soir nous propose une
virée en moto
mais il insiste pour que je conduise moi
je suis toujours partant pour ce genre
de trucs même si je sais pas très bien
conduire une moto j'ai assez vite
compris que ce qui me demandait la
dépasser le cadre d'une petite virée au
moment de démarrer sous le regard d'un
groupe d'hommes et de jeunes filles
j'hésite
j'ai peur de calais et qui charme se
rapproche de moi il dit non non non
c'est maintenant montrent que c'est
possible
alors j'ai réussi à démarrer et camille
qui photographe à nous était derrière en
train de prendre des photos je vous
laisse imaginer la tête des villageois
un autre passage des moments comme ça
j'en ai vécu quelques-uns pendant nos
deux années d'itinérance que ce soit
dans les steppes infinies de l'asie
centrale
bercé par les légendes de nomades
surtout quand vous avez des origines
turques que ça vous parle
à bord du transsibérien les yeux plongés
dans la taïga et les eaux du baïkal ou
encore au pied de mets mes montagnes du
pakistan retirer plusieurs mois
d'affilée d'une certaine forme de dison
modernité que ce soit au rythme du cargo
du train de la marche j'ai eu tout le
temps de réfléchir de me questionner
toutes ces expériences m'ont amené à
gommer des petites frontières que
j'avais moi même tracé sur ma carte
personnelle à 116 me demander qu'est ce
qui est similaire qu'est ce qui est
différent
qu'est ce que je ferai dans leur
contexte
qu'est-ce que je peux faire dans mon
contexte je suis entré cette année avec
une carte beaucoup plus lisible de qui
je suis et je souhaite être alors moins
évident ça moi c'est de continuer à
m'investir dans l'art de la
collaboration
l'intelligence du collectif au service
de l'écologie faire bon usage et
préserver nos ressources naturelles et
personnel ce qui à vrai dire ce qui me
préoccupe va bien au delà de mon
expérience personnelle
voyez toutes les singularités qu'on
essaye désespérément de gommer son des
richesses on est d'accord sont des
outils des clés de compréhension mais on
en fait quoi
franchement on s'enferme dans nos
cercles dans nos milieux on trace des
jolies frontières invisibles autour de
nous et là où le notre monde on se
limite on s'appauvrit on s'assèche et
puis toute cette énergie franchement
toute cette énergie passé à ne pas
s'assumer à se laisser définir par les
autres à fantasmer à baisser les bras
toute cette énergie perdue on gaspille
nos ressources
on se gaspille et moi le gaspillage
c'est un truc ça me révolte
et je vois
vraiment une urgence à changer tout ça
les défis qui sont à notre porte
aujourd'hui dont on a parlé un peu plus
tôt dans la journée la crise écologique
la crise sociale la nécessaire
réinvention nos modèles de société
franchement tout ça sera beaucoup moins
facile si on gaspille nos talents notre
énergie
et si on ferme la porte à celles et ceux
qui n'auraient pas la gueule de l'emploi
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya là un
gisement de potentiel de créativité
énorme
imaginez si chacun d'entre nous ici
individuellement vous vous vous vous là
bas au fond moi
imaginez si individuellement chacun
prenait sa place
de quoi nous serions capables
collectivement
moi je trouve ça assez prometteur mais
alors comment fait moi ça fait à peu
près mais 70 je me pose cette question
donc ça fait quoi 25 en deux ans de
pérégrinations trois mois d'affilée sous
une tente
manger des nouilles chinoises tout ça
tout ça je pense que vous pouvez en
faire l'économie
je crois qu'il ya bien plus de manière
de nourrir et d'affirmer la pluralité de
nos identités qui pour moi passent par
le rapport à l'autre c'est comme un
espèce de muscles entraîné ça peut-être
de faire ce premier pas de côté
ça peut être de créer des connexions en
dehors de nos cercles ou tout simplement
vous inscrire à ce cours d'art dont vous
rêvez depuis toujours aller parler à son
voisin vous croiser de temps en temps
lancé ce projet que vous avez en tête
réaliser ce rêve d'enfance
les voyages les rencontres même les
lectures sont de magnifiques occasions
d'être autres pour être soit multiplié
les à votre manière peut-être là tout de
suite en sortant de la salle fait ce
premier pas pour faire évoluer votre
carte du monde
vous l'avez compris moi je suis fasciné
par la géographie et un truc qui me
fascine avec les cartes
une carte c'est une représentation de la
réalité c'est une projection qui souvent
ne demande qu'à évoluer qu'à s'enrichir
alors je nous invite tous aller vers les
autres
sortir de nos cercles explorer 9 à 7
trouvez toutes ses manières pour amener
de la profondeur à nos cartes du relief
et sans cesse je crois se demander dans
quel monde nous voulons naviguer avec
merci
[Applaudissements]